ich meine die frage so zu sagen warum
markus söder mit dem sie ja eigentlich
mal ein ganz gutes verhältnis hatten so
schien es zumindest warum der jetzt so
liegen sie schießt können sich das
erklären wie schlimm das ist nicht wahr
markus hutter bringt als
ministerpräsident von bayern
die perspektive ein aus bayern und ich
verstehe euch das thema style ich würde
auch schneller impfen also ich hab doch
da gar keinen dissenz also manchmal bis
zu den eindruck alle glauben eigentlich
hätte durch impfstoffe im keller liegen
und wenn sie nicht ausgeben also das
soll auch keinen dissens auch ich meinen
sie hätten schneller bestellen müssen
das ist was die menschen kritisieren